Attackers can also use denial
of service attacks to disrupt
the network intrusion detection process.
Similar to denial of service attacks on
a network server such as a web server,
an attacker can send a lot of
traffic to the IDS to process.
The result is resource exhaustions,
for example, in CPU memory and
network bandwidth.
In other words, the network IDS may
not be able to analyze traffic and
such traffic may contain actual attacks.
That is, the attacker can first
denial service the IDS and
then launch the real attack.
Another attack approach is to abuse the
reactive nature of intrusion detection.
The intrusion detection
process is reactive because
when the IDS outputs an alert, the
security admin must analyze the alert.
Therefore, the attacker
can send a lot of traffic
that would trigger the alerts, for
example, by crafting packets that on
purpose contain signatures of attacks.
The goal is to overwhelm the response
system and the security admins.
And then the attacker can send
the real attack traffic that even if
it triggers an alert, the alert
will not be acting upon in time.
That is because the security admins are
so busy analyzing alerts of fake attack,
the real attack is not
analyzed until it's too late.